if it's classified it has a place and it
place isn't next to your Corvette in the
garage by the way it's also not at
Mar-A-Lago uh and by the way it wasn't
on your uh Blackberry when you were
Hillary Clinton the first time I dealt
with this when I sat on the Benghazi
committee with Jim Jordan and Trey Gowdy
when you had senior American officials
exchanging classified information across
an unsecured blackberry and you had all
this stuff in the server up at Hillary
Clinton's place in New York I lived this
where we were trying to unpack exactly
the risk she had created to America by
doing this my theory on this one again
not partisan classified information
protect it if it shouldn't be classified
if it's over classified fine
Declassified get it out release it to
the Washington Post sign me up but if
the decision was that this is needed to
protect an American secret or American
soldiers or Sailors or Airmen and
Marines somewhere in the world then for
goodness sakes no one not a president
not not a CI director or Secretary of
State no one should be absolved from
responsibility for managing that
information appropriately
So speaking of that administrative state
I'm sure you've seen some of the Twitter
file leaks and the and the emails that
went from intelligence agencies to the
employees at Twitter I mean were they
overstepping their bounds and and at
what point is that a violation of our
first amendment if the government is in
essence coercing a company to silence
people
yeah you can either have command and
control or you could have coercion in
this case right and the net effect is
identical uh I think you can think you
can pretty clearly see this was coercion
so lawyers can all tell us whether that
invokes the first step right if you have
government action or not I I don't
really
well here's what we know we we know with
absolute certainty that uh the political
actors in The White House were giving
guidance to these folks to censor
conservative ideas not Viewpoint neutral
not uh this is not about keeping the
Taliban or Isis off of Twitter that this
is about uh political actors seeking to
manipulate speech in America in a way
that promoted a governmental Viewpoint
that is dangerous I'm happy to say that
the American people can see it because
in the end Dave you know this most of
the recourse to your point about
accountability most of the recourse
comes through political accountability
uh justice departments are responsive to
the presidents that put them together
while they have a element of
Independence make no mistake about it
the Attorney General works for the
president United States of America and
we can see that plain as day to day in
the way Merrick Garland is delivering
this justice department and weaponizing
so much of what they're doing there so
let's let's talk about that actually
because obviously the big thing at the
moment are these classified documents
you know we went through six months ago
what Trump had at Mar-A-Lago and the
president is allowed to declassify
things but you know the media was
telling you the walls are closing in
again and okay it doesn't seem as as if
much has happened but now Biden's in the
midst of one of these scandals himself
what should the policy what actually is
the policy on this sort of thing like
one of the things that I've heard Biden
say a couple times is well it was a
small amount of documents as if that
somehow makes it a little bit better I'm
pretty sure you don't want any
classified docs out right is that is
that fair to say it seems right if it's
classified it has a place and it place
isn't next to your Corvette in the
garage by the way it's also not at
Mar-A-Lago uh and by the way it wasn't
on your uh Blackberry when you were
Hillary Clinton the first time I dealt
with this when I sat on the Benghazi
committee with Jim Jordan and Trey Gowdy
when you had senior American officials
exchanging classified information across
an unsecured blackberry and you had all
this stuff in the server up at Hillary
Clinton's place in New York I lived this
where we were trying to unpack exactly
the risk she had created to America by
doing this my theory on this one again
not partisan classified information
protect it if it shouldn't be classified
if it's over classified fine
Declassified get it out release it to
the Washington Post sign me up but if
the decision was that this is needed to
protect an American secret or American
soldiers or Sailors or Airmen or Marines
somewhere in the world then for goodness
sakes no we're not a president not not a
CI director or Secretary of State no one
should be absolved from responsibility
for managing that information
appropriately and so I hope this will be
managed in a way that is neutral and I'd
say one last thing Dave neutral in the
in two ways one it shouldn't be
political rsds conservatives liberals
but neutral also and I write about this
in the book we didn't prosecute we
didn't get any anything to Hillary
Clinton there were lots of young
soldiers Young Marines who had made
mistakes and how they handle classified
information they were punished and so we
should make sure that you don't get off
scott free just because you have power
and influence and you are punished if
you are someone who is more Junior
whether you're a gs-12 at the department
of energy or a
young private in the Marines we should
make sure that in America the law is
applied evenly both both left and right
and up and down that would be refreshing
I don't even know if you're allowed to
answer this next question but how how do
you guys actually decide what really is
that highest level classified is that is
there a standard policy on everything or
do they bring things to your desk and
you have people making Arguments for you
that you have to make that final call on
some of each so there's a process a
detailed classification process within
the United States government the
Department of Defense has a process the
intelligence agencies each have a
process they roughly mirror each other
but decision makers at every level are
making decisions about how to classify
their categories of things
if there are things about operatives
somewhere in the world it gets a certain
classified so there is a rubric designed
to try and get these classification
levels right look at the edge I'm sure
there's people making judgment calls
maybe some of them political I I didn't
see much of that inside the ca mostly I
saw people trying to get it right and
then there were many many occasions when
things were brought to me and for
whatever reason I wanted them
Declassified I felt it was important
that the American people knew I thought
that the risk whatever that might have
been two years ago five years ago was
diminished and so I would send back down
say we need to declassify this a little
bit of process but in the end between
the senior leadership and the president
we could always get it to the right
level of classification every handful of
times I went the other way I saw
something like what the what the heck is
that doing at free space we need to try
to make sure we secure that information
at least for a little while are you
worried at all that as people kind of
see how
dysfunctional Washington is or just how
crazy the machine seems to be as we've
you know because of Technology we can
look under the hood now in a way that
you couldn't say 40 years ago that that
we're not going to get the quality
person that you want working in these
agencies because people are just going
to say no I'd rather be in the private
sector I just see this thing as a as a
big freaking mess I mean I understand
you're saying there's obviously a lot of
great people there but that over time
that there will be a a sort of uh a
draining of that
yes I'm worried about in two respects
one in the true sense that you describe
good people will decide not worth the
candle yeah for financial reasons family
reasons who needs the headache reasons
all the above the second reason I worry
about this and I and I write about this
and and this is why you can't give an
inch
that's why I titled the book the way I
did the bias will be the people of the
left will say yeah I want to be part of
government and conservatives will say
I want to go live my life uh right
um and uh that bias I think already
exists inside these bureaucracies where
I come from a place where government is
something that you look at you go yeah
I'm a little skeptical and the private
sector should be flourishing and
delivering in churches and synagogues
and Boy Scout Troops that's the place
America was made and so conservatives
tend to say you know I'm good I'm living
here I'm living my great life in Texas
are my wonderful life in Southern
Illinois wherever you are and say you
know I went out and go to Washington for
and Liberals are dying for that power
and so not only not only do you have a
net decrease in talent that I worry
about and Excellence
um but you'll get a bias the best people
who are conservative thinkers uh people
who are good operators will say nah you
know I'm not going to go do that what do
you do about that I mean that one seems
almost unwinnable to me because that's
just the nature of power versus the
individual and you're just going to
self-select out because you want to go
do something in a functional free
atmosphere and that's not really the
government I mean is there any solution
to that yes I'm gonna I'm gonna provide
the solution right now wow to your
entire audience all right go go spend
some part of your life serving
doesn't have to be in Washington DC it
doesn't even have to be in government
but you know different people will be in
different parts of their life take a
couple years four years two whatever it
is and go surf you can do it as a deacon
at your church you can do that coaching
someone's literally baseball team you
can do it in Washington DC you can run
for city council or even better still
run for school board and go fix the crap
that's being taught in our schools today
and so I'm not only going to tell you
that there's a solution to this I'm
going to I'm going to be part of the
solution by urging people who who share
our value system who understand the
judeo-christian heritage of America in
the most fundamental way and say all
right I get it it's really wonderful to
be out here living my own life but at
some point in your 20s in your 30s in
your 50s whatever go spend a little bit
of time this is the greatest nation in
the history of civilization and we each
can find a way and a place to give back
just a little bit if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of mindless
dribble check out our politics playlist
list and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell